>>Liza: Games are great ways to
assess student learning in action.
They can help you figure out what
your students know and how they think.
Any kind of game has the
power to make student thinking
and doing visible, not
just digital games.
>>Two, four, three, Go to
there, go to there, go to there.
>>Three, four, give, six.
>>Bam, well you can still exchange it.
>>Liza: Choices that students make
during game play provide lots of data
about what they do and don't
understand, and how they apply skills,
like critical thinking
and problem solving.
Games also provide immediate feedback
to students about their choices,
so they can take control
of their own learning.
This brings you up to evaluate more
than just content knowledge and skills
for a deeper understanding of
what students are learning.
And the best part about
using games as assessments is
that sometimes students have
so much fun playing a game,
they don't even realize
they're being assessed.
>>Students: Three.
>>Teacher: Three.
>>Students: Two, one, go.
<students cheering>
>>Liza: So how do you assess
student learning using a game?
Step one, produce a product.
Students can create something
during game play
to show what they are learning.
For example, the goal of a
card game might be for students
to write a collaborative story, based
around the cards they are dealt.
Step two, question students.
You can develop a list
of probing questions
to ask students during game play.
As students play, move around the
classroom and ask those questions.
Step three, track moves.
Ask students to track the moves
they make during game play.
At the end of the game, you can evaluate
the choices they made while playing.
Step one, mod a game.
Modding a game means changing
one or two things about a game.
For example, you can ask students to
change one rule and then explain how
that impacts what they
are learning in the game.
Step two, design a game.
Ask students to design their own
games to reach the same learning goal.
Then students can play each
other's games, give feedback
and review content and skills.
Step three, write a strategy guide.
After playing a game, students
can use what they learned
to write their own strategy guides,
to help new players learn how to win.
Thanks for watching.
Stay tuned for more video
tips from Institute of Play.